This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档 I-Heart 播客。人类出品，必属精品。2%。这是指在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代世界中展现出的精神韧性、体能以及抗压能力的种种迹象。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将在历练后成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。节目名称中的 “2” 是英文单词 TWO。当一群女性发现她们约会的对象竟然都是同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子时，她们决定亲自讨回公道。我发誓，我一定要成为他最后的目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他罪有应得。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友们。听听女孩子们的劝告吧。相信我，宝贝。请在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。对我有重大意义的是1984年。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅聊80年代。1984年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that. you need to listen to learn the hard way on the iha radio app apple podcast or wherever you get your podcast
请在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话——这些对话在其他地方谈论实在不够安全，但在这里，你是在和一个懂得如何处理这些问题的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一身铠甲。这向全世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，你。就必须去听听在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Learn the Hardway》
hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today I'm going to cut straight to it. Let's talk about self-doubt. Let's talk about the negative beliefs that we all kind of have about ourselves that we carry through life, whether we are aware of it or not. Doubtes. about our worth, doubts about our talent, how deserving we are, our intelligence, just a couple,
大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，这是一档探讨我们20多岁时经历的重大生活改变与过渡，以及这些改变对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身处世界何地，很高兴你能来到这里，收听我们的又一期节目，当然，我们要一如既往地剖析20多岁的心理学。今天我开门见山直奔主题。我们来谈谈自我怀疑。我们来谈谈我们所有人对自我或多或少抱有的负面信念，那些无论我们是否意识到、都伴随我们一生的信念。怀疑。关于我们的价值，关于我们的才华，我们是否配得上这一切，我们的智力，这只是其中的一部分，
just to name a few, all of which end up really restricting our potential and they manifest in indecisiveness, in procrastination, self-sabotage and disappointment. I think it's a really rude awakening when you realize that so often the person who secretly is holding us back from so many of our visions and our dreams about the future and about our lives is us. The person who is saying no is us. The person rejecting us without ever giving us a chance is, you guessed it, ourselves. It's not always conscious, nor is it our fault. From a very early age, we get implanted with these false ideas of what makes us worthy and what we deserve, whether it's from our families, our childhood environment, our peers, myths that society tells us about who gets to be
随便列举几个，所有这些最终都极大地限制了我们的潜力，它们表现为优柔寡断、拖延症、自我设限和失望。我认为，当你意识到很多时候，那个在暗中阻碍我们实现未来和生活的种种愿景与梦想的人竟然是我们自己时，这真是一个相当残酷的觉醒。那个说“不”的人是我们自己。那个甚至不给我们任何机会就拒绝我们的人，你猜对了，就是我们自己。这并不总是有意识的，也不是我们的错。从很小的时候起，我们就被灌输了这些虚假观念，告诉我们什么才算有价值、什么才是我们应得的，无论这些观念来自我们的家庭、童年环境、同龄人，还是社会灌输给我们的、关于谁能成为成功者、谁能受到赞扬而谁又不能的神话，甚至包括我们在很小的时候经历的一些挫折和失败，这些挫折和失败真的深深地留在了我们心中。这些经历在我们内心变成了虚假信念，进而构成了我们的自我概念和自我价值的核心部分。这就形成了一种奇怪的循环：为了驱散这些信念，我们不得不加倍努力，把自己逼得更紧，去扮演一个并不是真正的自己的人，而大多数时候，这种做法不可避免地以失败告终。如果我们从未意识到这一点，它最终确实会给我们的潜力加上一个上限，并扰乱我们的指南针，动摇我们对自己的信任。
successful and praised versus who doesn't, even some of the setbacks and failures that we experience pretty early on that really stay with us. And these experiences become those false beliefs within us that in turn create a core part of our self-concept and our self-worth. And it kind of sets up this weird cycle where in order to disperse those beliefs, We have to try harder, push ourselves harder, be something that we're not, and that inevitably most of the time doesn't end up working. If we are never made aware of that, it can really end up putting a ceiling on our potential and kind of disrupting our compass, disrupting the trust that we have in ourselves.
我从自己十几岁到二十出头的亲身经历中深有体会。我对当时的自己感到非常不自在。我对自己做的几乎每一件事都充满怀疑，从我的学业到我的感情生活，再到我的创造力以及人际关系。因此，我真的阻止了自己去展现自我。甚至在开始之前，我就已经告诉自己我会失败的。你知道的，这甚至上升到了重大决策的高度，比如不去申请那些我本可能被录用的工作，不去申请那些我本可能拿到的奖学金，不去承担任何风险。
I know this from my own experience as a teenager and very much into my early 20s. I was so uncomfortable with who I was. I doubted about nearly every single thing that I did from, you know, my academics to my romantic life, to my, like, creativity, to my friendships. And so I really stopped myself from ever putting myself out there. Before I'd even begun, I was already telling myself that I was going to fail. And it, you know, went right to the top in terms of big decisions, like not applying for jobs that I may have gotten, not applying for scholarships that I may have gotten, not taking risks.
但这也体现在一些小决定上，比如我上课该穿什么？我该和谁说话？当我回首那段岁月时，心中百感交集，我想，既有悲伤，也有对那个被自我怀疑折磨得遍体鳞伤、对自己恶语相向、极度痴迷于完美却又绝不相信自己能做到的那个版本的自己的同情。但在过去的十年里，我不想说我踏上了一段“心灵之旅”，因为听起来太神秘太宗教了，但在很多方面确实如此，我意识到了生命如此短暂，世界如此广阔，人们都忙着关注自己，以至于根本没有人来制定规则。没有人说过你不能做到这一点，更没有人比你自己更清楚。当你意识到这一点时，当你意识到正是自己阻碍了自己时，你才真正有机会重塑自我、重塑生活，去真正做那些需要勇气、让你发自内心感到骄傲的事情，去真正倾听你的直觉。所以，这正是我今天要谈论的内容，我希望能教会你如何消除自我怀疑，我们将探讨这些负面虚假信念的根源，它是如何以非常隐蔽的方式表现出来的，为什么它会制造自我实现的预言，但最重要的是，我们该如何利用心理学、科学以及我们对“如何激励自己”与“如何自我设限”的认知，去真正突破我们的极限。我们今天要讨论的内容实在太多了。这期节目我一直在心里琢磨了很久。所以我很高兴能与大家分享，并希望通过它展示是什么帮助了我，同时也希望能帮你从中吸取教训。所以，废话不多说，
but also small decisions like what would I wear to class? Who would I speak to? And I look back at that chapter with so much, I think sadness, but also empathy for that version of me who was just crippled by self-doubt and spoke so negatively about themselves, was so obsessed with being perfect, never believed that she would be. But in the last decade, I don't want to say that I've been on a journey because that sounds so mystical and religious, but in many ways I have, this journey of realizing that life is short, the world is so big, people are so swept up in themselves that no one is making the rules. No one is saying you can't more than you. And when you realize that, when you realize that you're in your own way is when you really get the chance to reinvent yourself and re-event your
让我们深入探讨我们怀疑自己的心理背后究竟是什么原因，以及如何消除这些虚假的信念。当我们说自己正在与自我怀疑作斗争时，这可能意味着几层含义。也许你觉得自己在工作或学业上完全不够资格。你怀疑自己所处的位置，也许你身处领导岗位，也许并没有。你对自己的外表感到不安全。你怀疑是否会有人觉得你有吸引力。当你开口发言、发表意见、与他人互动时，你都会怀疑自己。也许你会通过寻求不断的安慰来弥补这一点。
life and actually do things that take courage that you're genuinely proud of and actually listen to your intuition. So that is exactly what I want to talk about today when I want to hopefully teach you today how to silence yourself doubt we're going to discuss the origins of those negative false beliefs how it shows up in you know very invisible ways why it can create a self-fulfilling prophecy but above all else how we can leverage the psychology the science our knowledge about how we motivate ourselves versus how we handicap ourselves to really push beyond our limiting beliefs we have so much to discuss today. This episode has been on my mind for a long time. So I'm excited to share it and hopefully show you what has helped me help you learn from this as well. So without further ado,
在做出关于未来的决定，甚至是日常的小决定时，你可能会拖延，这并不是因为你懒惰，也不是因为你优柔寡断，而是因为你对自己的正确抉择能力缺乏信心。这个名单还可以列下去。归根结底，就是觉得自己不够好，觉得自己不够有价值，因为担心自己一开始做不到完美而迟迟不敢开始。至于冒名顶替综合征，我们稍后再谈。所有这些个体的经历，共同构成了我们所谓的“自我怀疑”。
let's get into the psychology behind why we doubt ourselves and how to silence those false beliefs. When we say that we are struggling with self-doubt, that can mean a few things. Perhaps it's that you feel really unqualified at your job or at school. You, you're You doubt the position you're in, maybe you're in a leadership role, maybe you're not. You feel insecure about your appearance. You doubt whether anyone will ever find you attractive. You doubt yourself when you speak up when you contribute, when you interact with others. Maybe you compensate for that by seeking constant reassurance.
这一切的核心，其实是对自己以及自身能力缺乏或失去了信任。我们每个人都有这样一座内部指南针，它不仅指引着我们，还受我们对自身价值的根深蒂固的信念所引导。正是这种价值赋予了我们前行的信心，相信我们正在做的事情的信心，以及高度评价自己的信心。当我们经历压倒性的自我怀疑时，这表明那座指南针坏了。它在北方和南方之间摇摆不定。归根结底，怀疑就是这样。犹豫不决。你知道的，这一刻我觉得自己很有价值，下一刻又觉得，不，我没有。我是个有才华的人。不，我没有。我应该选择这条路，或者也许我该选A路径？不，选B路径，我不确定。而这个指南针
When it comes to making a decision about your future or even small, everyday decisions, you might procrastinate, not because you're lazy, not because you're indecisive, because you aren't confident in your ability to choose correctly. This list could go on. Basically, it's not feeling good enough, not feeling worthy enough, hesitating to start something new because you might not be perfect from the get-go. Imposter syndrome, we're going to get to that later. All of these individual experiences are what make up what we would call self-doubt.
不会凭空坏掉。没有人天生就会怀疑自己。如果你身边有小孩子，你就会发现，只要他们一开始学会爬行，他们就会向前冲，或者攀爬任何表面，而且他们从不觉得自己会摔倒。他们有着一种无法抑制的好奇心，渴望去探索、去实验，他们从未对自己的直觉产生过哪怕一次怀疑。然而，随着我们自我意识的增强，虽然有时我们的怀疑是为了我们好，但外在力量也开始侵入，
What it all boils down to is a lack or a loss of trust in yourself and your own abilities. Each of us has this internal compass that not only guides us but is guided by our deeply rooted beliefs about our value. And that value is what gives us confidence to forge ahead, confidence to believe in what we're doing, confidence to hold ourselves highly. When we experience overwhelming self-doubt, it indicates that that compass is broken. It's starting between north and south. And that's what doubt is at the end of the day. in decision. You know, one moment I'm worthy, the next moment, no, I'm not. I'm talented. No, I'm not. I should choose a path, or maybe I should choose path A, no path B, I'm not sure. And this compass
并开始让我们对自我产生怀疑，而这往往始于我们最主要的“罪魁祸首”，那就是我们的父母和我们的童年环境。我知道说这话听起来再显眼不过了，但我们早期的童年时光对我们的塑造至关重要。我们的大脑就像一块巨大的海绵、一张巨大的画布，吸收着向它投射的一切，无论这些是积极的还是消极的。当然，有些经历更为重要，
doesn't get broken on its own. No one is born doubting themselves. If you are around children, you will see as soon as they can start crawling how they dart forward, or they climb any surface, and they never realize that they can fall. And they have this uncontrollable desire to be curious, and to explore and to experiment, they never once question their instincts. As we gain greater self-awareness, though, obviously sometimes our doubts are for our own good, but also external forces begin to intrude
特别是当它们涉及到我们与主要抚养者之间的纽带时，因为我们（你知道的）在生物学和天性上就更倾向于关注那些与我们建立安全或可能是不安全依恋关系的人。因此，举例来说，父母过度的批评会让我们在很小的时候就深深地怀疑自己。如果你有一个父母——如果你现在还有一个对你过度挑剔的父母，你做任何事都不够好，你让他们失望，你惹他们生气，你没有达到他们的期望，而且他们不仅仅通过责骂进行善意的引导，而是让你清楚地知道这一切，甚至在你拼尽全力想让他们满意时也从不给予你夸奖，
and they begin to cause us to question ourselves, starting with what always tends to be our main culprit, which is our parents and our childhood environment. I know it sounds really, really obvious to say, but our early childhood years are so formative. Our brain is like this big sponge, this big canvas that is taking in everything that is thrown at it, whether that is positive or not. And there are, of course, some experiences that are more significant,
你最后就会想，你知道的，如果这个人都不因为我的努力而爱我，那我真的配得到爱吗？我甚至能相信自己吗？我太想让他们开心了，可我不知道该怎么做，哪怕我已经尽力了。这导致我们对一切都开始产生第二次猜测，因为我们变得害怕出错，我们开始内化这种缺乏支持的声音或是他们说的话，而自我怀疑的种子就在那一刻被悄然埋下。这种情况也可能在我们与兄弟姐妹进行比较时出现，我们再次内化了一种信念：与他们相比，与我们在这种被营造出来的竞争关系中相比，我们永远无法达标，我们在父母眼中永远不够好，他们永远会有最偏爱的孩子，
especially when they relate to the bond that we share with our primary caregiver because we are, you know, biologically and naturally attuned to pay closer attention to those in which we have a secure, maybe insecure attachment to. So excessive parental criticism, for one, can cause us to really doubt ourselves from quite an early age. If you have a parent, if you still have a parent who is overly critical of you, nothing is good enough, you disappoint them, you annoy them, you don't live up to their expectations, and they let you know that beyond just kind guidance through scolding, never giving you praise even when you try your hardest to do what they want.
而那个最受偏爱的永远不会是我们，这再次引发了自我怀疑。我要给出的最后一个例子，它有点概括了之前的所有例子，但基本上就是当我们面对那些永远无法满足的高期望时。并不是说当我们达不到这些期望时仍然能收获爱。当我们达不到期望时，迎来的可能是批评、忽视、惩罚，某种——我不知道——行为或管教，这实际上在瓦解我们真实的自我。而我们的价值感确实开始因此而削弱。事实上，根据内华达大学的研究，导致成年后产生冒名顶替综合征的一个重大因素就是过度挑剔的父母，那些无论你做什么——无论是获得的荣誉、成就，还是百般讨好、拼命想取悦他们——都永远觉得不够好的父母。因此，你的指南针再次失去了方向。这是一类导致我们天生缺乏自信的经历。但这不仅仅是父母的问题。显然，同龄人也是早期环境中占很大比重的一部分。而且你知道吗？我觉得同龄人对我们造成的某些痛苦并没有得到足够的认可，如果这也能算是一种“认可”的话。
you end up thinking, you know, if this person doesn't love me for what I'm trying to do, am I even worthy of love? Can I even trust myself? I want to please them so much, but I don't know how, even when I try. This causes us to really second guess everything, because we become afraid of misstepping, and we begin to internalize the lack of support or the words that they say, and the seeds of self-doubt are really kind of sewn at that moment. This can also emerge when we are compared to siblings, for example, and we, again, internalize a belief that compared to them, compared to this rivalry that is set up between us, we will never measure up, we will never be good enough for our parents, they will always have a favorite,
除了父母，同龄人可以说是最大的影响源。而他们的影响，一方面可能并不积极，另一方面，随着我们年龄增长、进入青少年时期，这种影响往往会加剧。我们最想要留下好印象的人就是我们的朋友。我可以滔滔不绝地讲述童年霸凌对成年后自尊心的影响，这期节目甚至可以讲上好几个小时，因为这个话题往往不为人所谈论。我们常常倾向于认为，一旦我们离开了那个环境，一旦我们把学校抛在脑后，把那些霸凌者抛在身后，天哪，我们就可以拍拍手告别了，一切都结束了，我们可以向前看了。所有那些负面情绪反应都会消失。但如果你在10年、15年前经历过这些，
and that favorite will never be us, and that again creates self-doubt. The final example I'll give of this, which kind of underlines all. of the previous examples, but it's basically when there are these high expectations that we can never meet. And it's not that when we don't meet them, we're still met with love. When we don't meet them, we are perhaps met with criticism, neglect, punishment, some kind of, I don't know, behavior or like discipline that actually undermines who we are. And our sense of value does begin to weaken in response to that. In fact, according to research by the University of Nevada, a big factor that actually contributes to imposter syndrome later in life is hypercritical parents, hypercritical parents who,
在那段我们所有人都会经历的、非常非常脆弱的时期，在那段极具塑造力的时期，那些遭受霸凌、被排挤、遭受（社会上、身体上、言语上的——我不太喜欢“虐待”这个词，但确实是）霸凌的经历并不会轻易消失。而且，你知道的，15年过去了，当你尝试新事物、或者在职场上争取晋升、或者试图突破自我极限去扩展自己时，你的脑海里可能仍然会听到那些声音，因为在你的自我概念正在形成的时期，那些声音实在是太刺耳了。
no matter what you did, the accolades, the achievements, fawning, trying so hard to please them, it was never good enough. And so once again, your compass loses direction. That is one set of experiences that contributes to a very innate lack of belief in ourselves. But it's not just our parents. It's our peers that obviously also make up a big part of that early environment. And you know what? I don't think our peers get enough credit for some of the pain that they cause, if we can even call it credit.
你知道的，遭受霸凌——无论是身体上的、言语上的、社交上的，还是被排挤、孤立——已经被证明会字面意义上改变我们的大脑。原因是在我们青春期神经元正在快速布线和重新布线的阶段，我们暴露于压力荷尔蒙皮质醇的水平有所增加。这意味着什么呢？简而言之，受过霸凌的人的大脑和没有受过霸凌的人的大脑看起来会有很大不同。具体来说，是在我们环境中处理危险的区域，特别是在像杏仁核这样处理恐惧的情绪大脑回路中，以及在大脑中处理一种特定痛苦——即社会痛苦的区域中，
Next to our parents, our peers are like the biggest influence. And their influence is sometimes, A, not positive, but B, just tends to increase the order we get when we get into our teen years, the people that we are mainly concerned with impressing are our friends. The way that I could go on about the impact of childhood bullying on adult self-esteem, this episode would be hours long because it's not spoken about. We often tend to think of, you know, once we leave that environment, once we leave school behind, once we leave our bullies behind, oh my gosh, we can kind of wash our hands of this, we're done, we can move forward. All of those negative emotional reactions disappear. But if you went through that 10, 15 years ago
这种痛苦伴随着被拒绝、失落、被排挤的经历。当研究人员观察其长期后果时，发现儿童时期遭受过霸凌的人表现出更高的社交焦虑水平、更高的完美主义倾向，当然还有自我怀疑。在那段时期，我想我们大家都有所记忆。我们真的、真的非常在意别人对我们的看法。我们真的很在意自己是否有足够的朋友。
during that really, really vulnerable period that we all go through, you know, during that really formative period, it's not like those experiences of being bullied, of being excluded, of being, you know, socially, physically, verbally, I don't like the term abuse, but yeah, bullied. those experiences don't necessarily go away. And, you know, 15 years on, you might still hear those voices in your head when you're trying something new or when you're going for a promotion at work, when you're trying to push beyond your own limits and extend yourself because those voices were just so loud during a time when your self-concept was being formed.
我们真的很在意那些所谓的酷女孩或酷男孩——他们在不在乎我们是否也那么酷。这就像是一种持续不断的社交焦虑，在水面之下嗡嗡作响。而当周围的人不断打击你的自信时，无论是通过捉弄、批评，还是对你的成绩、衣着评头论足，你都会失去对自己的那份天然信任，
You know, being bullied, whether that is physical or verbal or social or, you know, exclusion, that has been shown to quite literally change the brain due to an increased exposure to the stress hormone cortisol during that period during our adolescence where our neurons are wiring and rewiring quite rapidly. What that basically means is that the brain of someone who was bullied versus the brain of someone who wasn't are going to look very different. Specifically in the regions that process danger in our environment, specifically in our emotional brain circuits like the amygdala that processes fear, and the areas of our brain that process a specific kind of pain called social pain,
你也会失去对自身价值的那种天然信任，从而选择退缩。你把自己庇护起来，免受这些同样的人或同样的经历带来的潜在伤害或二次打击。而你保护自己的方式，就是不再展现自我，不再把自己推向世界，因为这些经历教给你的道理是：当你这样做时，
the pain that follows experiences of rejection, of loss of ostracism. When they looked at the long-term consequences of this, people bullied as children showed heightened levels of social anxiety, heightened levels of perfectionism, and of course self-doubt. During that time, I think we can all kind of remember this. We really, really care about what others think about us. We really care about whether we have enough friends.
你就是在向潜在的伤害敞开自己，向潜在的被排挤、孤立或批评敞开自己，而你不想再去承受这些了。这太痛苦了。所以，避免承受这种痛苦最简单的方法，就是永远不要把自己置于那个位置。这是因为，我认为自我怀疑中有一个我们尚未谈及的方面，那就是它其实是一种自我保护的形式。它是一种心理防御机制，通过极其谨慎的方式、通过要求我们反复核对、通过要求我们稳妥行事并让自己呆在舒适区而非不适区，来保护我们免受潜在的负面结果或情感痛苦。你知道，小孩子们真的很残酷，想到我们当时都那么年幼，
We really care about what the cool girl, a cool guy, like whether they think that we're all so cool. Like it's just this constant social anxiety that is buzzing below the surface. And when people around you drill away at your confidence, whether that is teasing, whether that is, you know, criticizing you, whether that is slight comments about your grades, your clothes, you lose that innate trust you have in yourself
却因为童年的那种残忍，而具备了对我们的自我认知以及世界观造成这种（可以说是）半长期损害的能力，这着实让人感到悲伤。而当你的个性中本就带有完美主义、或者你是一个敏感的灵魂、又或者你的基础焦虑水平很高时，这种伤害对我们自我怀疑的影响绝对会被进一步放大。你知道的，如果你是一个敏感的孩子，就像我曾经的那样。就像我们许多人曾经的那样，这些事情真的很难让人忘记。而且，我们的记忆往往对负面经历更为敏感，
and you lose that kind of innate trust you have in your value and you withdraw. You shelter yourself away from potentially being hurt again or being bruised again by these same people or these same experiences. And the way that you shelter yourself is by no longer showing up, by no longer putting yourself out there because what this has taught you is that when you do
因为我们有着消极偏误。所以，如果你现在仍然觉得自己仿佛在经历童年霸凌或青少年霸凌所带来的创伤，老实说，我认为你的这种感受是完全合情合理的。我认为这些经历并不会像大多数人让我们以为的那样轻易消失。另一个真正让我们深陷自我怀疑的因素——特别是当我们年龄渐长，尤其是处于十几岁后期、二十岁出头的时候——是有毒或混乱的亲密关系。谈到爱情，这听起来可能显而易见，但正是在那里，我们最为脆弱。
that you open yourself up to the potential to be hurt, to the potential to be excluded or isolated or criticized, and you don't want to endure that. It's painful. So the easiest way to not endure that is to not ever put yourself out there. This is because I think one aspect of self-doubt we haven't spoken on yet is that it really is a form of self-protection. It is a psychological defense mechanism because it shields us from potentially negative outcomes or emotional pain by being extremely cautious, by asking us to double check, by asking us to play it safe and to keep ourselves in a place of comfort rather than discomfort. You know, kids are so cruel and it's quite sad to think that despite all of us being so young
因此，当我们信任某人，或者当我们极其渴望他们回应我们的关注与爱意，而这种渴望最终却变成了侮辱，或者他们拒绝了我们，或者他们对待我们的方式让我们觉得自己要求太多、自己只是次要选择时，这确实会造成真正的情感伤害。我们在上周关于“红旗信号”（Red Flags）的节目中讨论过这一点。我们当时引用了一项2019年的研究，该研究表明负面恋爱经历如何在我们的自尊心发展中起到作用，而自尊心正是引发自我怀疑的主要因素之一。对于任何不幸经历过被自己关心或喜欢的人亲手摧毁自信的人来说，这简直再好理解不过了。你真的会开始失去对自己的信任，因为你会觉得：“怎么会有人对另一个人的看法错得这么离谱？”尽管这其实并不是你的错，但这一切又回到了起点：“等等，这是我自己的选择。我选择了一个可能会这样对我的伴侣，或者万一他们说的是真的呢？如果我真的那么喜欢他们，他们身上一定有可取之处。他们一定比我更了解我自己。”所以，正是这些早期的恋爱关系，甚至是最近的恋爱关系，再次深深地钻进我们的大脑，让我们对自己选择去做的几乎所有事情都产生怀疑。
at the time, we were capable of doing this, you know, semi-long-term damage to how we see ourselves and the world because of that childhood cruelty. And the impact that this has on our self-doubt is definitely heightened when you already have innate personality traits like perfectionism or you're a sensitive soul or you have a high baseline level for anxiety. You know, if you are a sensitive kid, I'll go back to that example like I was. Like I'm sure many of us were, these things can be incredibly hard to forget. And also our memory is often more attuned to negative experience.
除此之外，我们还会经历失败和挫折。要知道，20多岁正是经历这些的黄金时期，因为这绝对是我们第一次真正独立。我们不再有父母、老师或学校作为安全网来接住我们。因此，我们的每一个举动、每一种行为，都要由自己负责。有时事情就是不会按我们期望的方向发展。这会导致我们退缩，并开始怀疑我们的那座指南针。生活中总会有那么一些时刻，我们已经尽力了。我们做了自认为正确的事，但结果却事与愿违。我们所有人都有过这样的经历。我记得有几个这样的例子。其中一次是我去申请大学里的某项奖学金，觉得自己表现得很棒，结果却没拿到，被退回了。而那段经历最终让我深表感激，但这又是另一个故事了。我能想到的另一个例子是，我曾为一篇论文付出了巨大的努力。那是我在大学里的第一篇论文之一，结果我得了55分。从宏观角度来看，这只是一个小挫折。我甚至说不出那篇论文到底写的是什么。我说不出它的开头，也说不出任何与那篇论文相关的内容。但我清楚地记得我得了那个分数。那个分数让我质疑了自己对自己的所有认知。我一直以为自己很聪明。我以为（你知道的）自己很有抱负。我以为自己适应能力很强，但这个结果却证明并非如此。既然如此，我又该如何信任自己的判断呢？当时身处那种竞争激烈的氛围中，这种状况更是雪上加霜。每个人似乎都做得很好。每个人都在成功。只有我一个人跟不上进度。我渴望证明自己配得上留在那里的资格。显然，在我的脑海里，当我拿到那个55分时，我证明了恰恰相反的事。我向自己证明了我不配待在那里。在那之后的几个月里，我甚至还清晰地记得这样一个极其具体的场景：当时我在写另一篇论文，针对开头的一句话改了又改、删了又删，几乎快要哭出来，被这篇论文折磨得动弹不得。“这写得好吗？我觉得挺好的。我觉得这挺好，但我怎么能确定呢？因为我觉得上一篇论文也挺好，结果却错了。”这就引回了冒名顶替综合征。你想听点真正具有讽刺意味但又挺搞笑的事情吗？至少我觉得挺搞笑的。我这档播客的第一期节目主题就是冒名顶替综合征。那是三年多以前的事了，尽管我做了这么多年的心理调适，但我并不觉得自己在这方面的应对能力有任何提升。冒名顶替综合征深深根植于那些由核心记忆和核心经历引发的大量怀疑之中，无论你向自己证明了多少次你配得上你的成功和成就，无论你把自己逼得有多紧、做了多少事、取得了多大的成就，
as we have a negativity bias. So if you're still feeling like you're reliving the trauma from a childhood bully or a teenage bully, I honestly think that that is quite a valid thing for you to be experiencing. I think that those experiences don't disappear as fast as most people would lead us to believe. Another thing that really causes us to get buried in self-doubt, especially the older we get, especially when we are in our late teenage years, early 20s are toxic or chaotic relationships. when it comes to love, I know it sounds so obvious, but, you know, that is where we are most vulnerable.
你始终被这样一种恐惧所纠缠：总有一天，你周围的人或那些重要的人会意识到你其实是个骗子。你在等待另一只靴子落地，尽管你可能已经非常优秀、非常实至名归，但因为你无法信任自己的评估能力，哪怕你拥有全世界所有的证据、所有的赞誉、所有的晋升、一切的一切，你仍然会觉得自己是在糊弄某人。你仍然会觉得是别人犯了错，或者你只是走了狗屎运。冒名顶替综合征的问题在于，在某事上做得很好的经历并不能改变你的信念。那种想法依然会在你的脑海深处喋喋不休。“究竟是什么给了我站这里的权利？”你取得的成就越多，（你知道的）你反而越觉得自己是个骗子，越觉得你把更多的人给蒙蔽了。这就好像你根本无法内化自己成功的经历。归根结底，这就是自我怀疑，
And so when we trust somebody or when we really want them to return our attention and our affection and that turns around and becomes insults or they reject us or they treat us like we're too much, that we're second best, that does some real emotional damage. And we talked about this on last week's episode on Red Flaggs. There was a 2019 study that we referenced that shows. how negative romantic experiences play a role in the development of our sense of self-esteem, and our self-esteem is a primary contributing factor to our sense of self-doubt. This makes a lot of sense for anyone who has unfortunately had an experience with someone
永远觉得自己不够好，永远觉得自己没有权利站在自己所处的位置上。这种冒名顶替综合征会把我们推向光谱的一个极端：我们过度专注于追求卓越，把自己越逼越紧，最终导致精疲力竭。我们最终甚至无法实现任何自己想要的目标，因为我们实在太累了。而在另一方面，它也可能把我们推向光谱的另一个极端：我们开始自我破坏或自我设限。有一句名言完美地总结了这一点：“人们永远无法超越他们对自己的看法。”这话虽然尖锐却无比真实，这正是自我设限和自我破坏的真实写照。
you cared about or who you liked has been the same person to break down your confidence. You really end up losing trust in yourself because you feel like, how could I have been so wrong about someone? even though it's not your fault, it all comes back to, wait, this was a choice for me. I chose someone who was going to maybe treat me like this or what if what they're saying is true. If I really like them, there must be something good about them. They must know something about me that I don't. So it's those early romantic relationships, even our recent romantic relationships that can once again really furrow into our brain and make us doubt almost
如果你对自己的看法是：我不配拥有这一切，我根本不知道自己在做什么，我格格不入，别人都知道我是个骗子，我还不够好（这份名单还可以列下去），那么当机会来临、需要你证明自己并非如此、需要你迈向那个向自己证明这些信念是错误的新版本时，这个过程会让人感到极其不适，并且与你的诸多固有信念相矛盾，以至于你会选择自我设限。自我设限是一种针对“对自身能力感到不确定”的行为反应，我们会下意识地在外部寻找理由来为自己的行为开脱，以此保护自己免受“觉得自己不够优秀”的伤害。你知道的，如果你横竖都要失败，为什么不按自己的方式去失败，以此来避免把自己推出去却惨遭羞辱的尴尬呢？为什么要去申请那份从客观条件来看你明明堪称完美的工作，如果你打心底里觉得自己会被拒绝？为什么要在网上发布那张照片或展示自我，如果你明知人们会对此嗤之以鼻？为什么不直接免去自己的尴尬，去向那个人发出约会邀请，哪怕你明知对方会拒绝？为什么不好好省省心呢？
everything that we choose to do. Beyond that, we also have experiences of failure and of setbacks. And, you know, our 20s are right for them because it is definitely one of the first times. It is the first time that we are truly independent. And we don't have the safety net of our parents or our teachers or of school to catch us. So our moves, our behaviors, they're all our own. And sometimes it just doesn't go our way. And that causes us to retreat and doubt the compass. There will be times in which we did our best. We did what we thought was right. And it did not go according to plan. We all have them. I remember a few instances like this. One was when I went for this scholarship at my university, thought I did great, didn't get it, got knocked back. And that was
这种现象的表现形式实在是太多了。希望你们能明白我的意思。自我怀疑如果不加以遏制，会让我们在无意中限制自己、限制我们的潜力，让我们与那些甚至能改变命运的机会失之交臂，因为我们根本不敢相信这些机会会属于像我们这样的人。自我怀疑的另一种表现形式是优柔寡断，有些人甚至会认为这其实是一种自我破坏或自我设限，是一种潜意识里的自我破坏或自我设限形式。
something that I ended up being really grateful for, but that's a story for another time. And another example I was thinking of was when I worked really hard on this assignment. And it was like one of my first assignments at uni and I got a 55%. That is a small setback in the scheme of things. I could not tell you what the paper was about. I could not tell you the opening I could not tell you like anything to do with that paper. But I remember that I got that grade. And that grade made me question everything about who I thought I was. I thought that I was smart. I thought that, you know, that I was ambitious. I thought that I was adaptable and this kind of proved me otherwise. And how could I trust my judgment now? It really didn't help that I was in this
你知道的，优柔寡断往往伴随着在我们做出决定之前进行过度的思考和过度分析，甚至到了最后什么都没做。当然，仔细思考你的决定是件好事。保持一定程度健康的怀疑精神和谦逊态度也是件好事，否则我们就会走向傲慢的极端。但如果我们其实只是害怕失败，或者我们只是害怕做出错误的决定，因为我们不相信自己有能力应对这个新阶段、新机遇带来的挑战，那么我们实际上就是在给自己一次机会之前就已经率先放弃了。最让人痛心的事实是，在任何人开口之前，是我们自己通过优柔寡断先说出了那个“不”。在那些时刻，我们甚至在不知不觉中成为了自己最大的敌人。因为在我们的脑海里，我们只是在努力做出正确的决定。我们只是在竭尽全力权衡所有的利弊，但实际上，这种“分析瘫痪”正是确保我们永远不必去突破“证明自我怀疑是错误的”那种不适感的一种方式。有趣的是，人们可能会把这样的人称为懒散，或者我们可能会（你知道的）称他们为拖延症患者，因为从表面上看，这或许就是它呈现出的样子。但在这这一切的背后，是一套
competitive atmosphere. Everyone seemed to be doing so well. Everyone was succeeding. It was just me who couldn't keep up. And I wanted to kind of prove that I deserve to be there. And obviously, in my mind, when I got that 55%, I proved the opposite. I proved to myself that I did not deserve to be there. In the months after that, I remember actually this really specific instance of writing this other essay and going back and forth and back and forth on the opening line, almost feeling like I was going to cry, feeling paralyzed by this paper. Like, is this good? I think it is. I think this is good, but how can I tell? Because I thought that my last paper was good and I was wrong. And this leads back to imposter syndrome. You want to know something really ironic, but also quite funny. I find
已经被不安全感腐蚀的信念系统，而这套系统对周围的所有人来说都是隐形的。
it funny at least. My very first episode of this podcast was on imposter syndrome. That was over three years ago and I don't think I have gotten any better at dealing with it despite all the years of work that I've done. Imposter syndrome is rooted in a lot of that doubt that comes from a lot of those really core memories and core experiences and no matter how much you prove to yourself that you deserve your successes, your achievements, no matter how far you push yourself, how much you do, how much you achieve. You are constantly followed by this fear that one day the people around you or the people that matter are going to realize that you are a fraud. You are waiting for this other shoe to drop despite the fact that you are probably really accomplished and really deserving, but because you don't
其声音的化身就是我们的内在批判者。这种声音在我们脑海里化作了一种非常响亮、喋喋不休的噪音，仿佛在说：“你做不到。你还不够好。想象一下所有可能出错的事情吧。想象一下，当某个重要人物意识到你一直在说谎、你是个骗子、你根本无法胜任时，会发生什么。”既然明知这可能会让我们付出沉重的代价——
trust your own assessments, you can have all the evidence in the world, all the praise, all the promotions, everything. And you will still feel like you tricked somebody. You will still feel like somebody made a mistake or you just got lucky. The problem with imposter syndrome is that the experience of doing well at something does not change your beliefs. That thought still nags in the back of your head. You know, what gives me the right to be here? The more you accomplish, you know, the more you actually feel like a fraud, the more you feel like you've tricked even more people. It's as though you can't internalize your experience of success. At the end of the day, it's self-doubt. it's never feeling good enough, it's never feeling like you have the right to be where you are.
比如我们的梦想生活、丰富的人生、爱情、友情、金钱、机遇——我们该如何应对呢？
That imposter syndrome can push us to one end of the spectrum where we are so focused on overachieving and pushing ourselves harder and harder that we end up burning out. We end up not being able to achieve anything that we want to because we are so exhausted. And on the other hand, it can also push us to the other end of the spectrum where we self-sabotage or we self-handicap. There is this quote that perfectly summarizes this for me. People never rise above the opinions of themselves. That is so harsh, but it is so true, and it is exactly what I mean by self-handicapping and self-sabotaging.
我们该如何让那个声音、那个内在批判者、那个自我怀疑闭嘴？我有很多建议要分享给大家，接下来会有非常多的实用技巧，包括“人格面具”的力量、“分身”的力量、为什么我们需要接触失败，以及为什么我们应该去怀疑我们的自我怀疑。所有这些内容以及更多精彩，将在短暂的广告休息之后为您呈现。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，
If your opinion is that you are undeserving, that you don't know what you're doing, that you are out of place, people know you're a fraud, you're not good enough, the list goes on, when the chance comes for you to prove otherwise and to step into. into a version of you that shows yourself that those beliefs are wrong, it is so uncomfortable and it contradicts so many of your beliefs that you self-handicap. Self-handicapping is a behavioral response to feeling uncertain about our abilities, where we unconsciously find an outside source to blame for our behaviors that protect us from feeling inadequate. You know, if you're already going to fail, why not fail on your own? own terms to avoid the embarrassment of putting yourself out there. Why apply for that job you
我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代世界中展现出的精神韧性、体能以及抗压能力的种种迹象。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与体能专家等展开对话，
are objectively are perfect for if you believe you're going to be rejected? Why post that photo or put yourself out there online if you know people are already going to laugh at it? Why ask that person on a date when you know they'll say no? Why not just save yourself the awkwardness? You know, it shows up in so many ways. Hopefully you get what I'm getting at. Self-doubt when unkindled. contained causes us to unconsciously limit ourselves and limit our potential by letting sometimes life-changing opportunities pass us by and not acting because we can't possibly think that they'd be for somebody like us. The other way that this manifests is in indecisiveness, which some people would actually argue
以此看清那些主导健康产业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经笃信种子油天然具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在历练后成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在 I-Hart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。节目名称写作 T-W-O-P-P-Cent。
is a form of self-sabotage or a form of self-handicapping, an unconscious form of that. you know, indecisiveness involves very much overthinking and over-analyzing our decisions before we make them, perhaps to the point that we never do. Obviously, it's a good thing to think through your decisions. It's good to have some healthy level of skepticism and humility. Otherwise, we do veer too far into the path of arrogance. But if we are actually just scared to fail or if we are actually just scared of making the wrong decision because we don't trust our ability to meet the demands of this new chapter of this new opportunity, we are actually self-abandoning before we even gave ourselves a chance. And it's devastating that we are the ones who said no throughout
app、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上拍了两下莉莉·金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不关爱黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉莉·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。
indecisiveness before anybody else could. We were our kind of biggest enemies in those moments without perhaps even realizing it. Because in our mind, we were just trying to make the right decision. We were just trying to really weigh up all the pros and cons, but actually that analysis paralysis is a way of making sure that we never have to push past the discomfort of proving our self-doubts wrong. It's interesting because people might call these kinds of individuals lazy or we might, you know, call them procrastinators because at face value, maybe that's what it looks like. But underneath it all is this belief system. that has become rotten by insecurity, that is invisible to everyone around us.
我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，他畅谈了80年代的可卡因风潮。澄清一下，1984年对我很重要，不单单是因为可卡因。我随时准备聊聊那个时代的可卡因，不过先让大家知道这一点。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在还要讨论艾滋病。
And is, you know, the voice of that is our inner critic. The voice of that is this very loud, nagging sound in our head of like, you can't do that. You're not good enough. Imagine everything that could go wrong. Imagine when somebody important is going to realize that you've lied, that you're a fraud, that you can't perform. knowing what this may be costing us, you know, our dream life, a rich life, love, friendship, money, opportunities. What do we do about it?
谢谢你帮我把这句话补全。是的。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《Look Back at It》。
How do we silence that voice, that inner critic, that self-doubt? I have so many tips for you, so many tips coming up, including the power of a persona, the power of an alter ego, why we need exposure to failure, and why we should be doubting our self-doubts. All of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
我们如何让那个声音、那个内心的批评者、那个自我怀疑闭嘴？我有太多的建议要分享给你们，接下来会有很多妙招，包括人格的力量、另一个自我的力量、为什么我们需要接触失败，以及为什么我们应该怀疑自己的自我怀疑。这一切以及更多内容，将在稍后的小憩之后揭晓。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more. to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Cent on the I-Hart Radio.
我剖析了精神韧性、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等人交谈，看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油天生会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一面成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即I-Harte电台上的T-W-O-P-P-Cent。
app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jette. And I'm Alex English.
应用程序、Apple Podcasts，或任何你收听播客的地方。还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击莉儿·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉儿·金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all. all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
在每一集中，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，滔滔不绝地畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊快克，但为了让大家知道我的意思。我是说，马克，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到其中有一条主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了桌面上。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the. the iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
谢谢你补全了那句话。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at It》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kier Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses
欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会太过于投入这场追逐，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却仍然在追逐，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是盯着生活的记分牌，生活变成了一场场胜负的较量。
Steve Burns Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟，绝对是，这是两个不同层面的信任，我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了长达数年的真相证明法庭之战。
You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Naranjini.
你对这个特定的测试作假了两次，对吧？我只作假了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一种令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格、一个女同性恋者、迈克尔·纳兰吉尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有诈骗罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
Knowing that we have negative doubts about ourselves is one thing. I think addressing them is a whole other base. because we are essentially now tasked with undoing a whole belief system, one which, you know, the evidence would tell us has been around for many, many years, probably longer than we have been aware of it. So let's break down how we can kind of regain control over your self-doubt. Firstly, really go behind your negative thoughts and your negative self-beliefs and ask, what are you actually afraid of?
知道我们对自己有消极的怀疑是一回事。我认为解决这些怀疑则是完全不同的基础。因为我们现在基本上要承担起消除整个信仰体系的任务，你知道，证据告诉我们这个信仰体系已经存在了非常非常多年，可能比我们意识到它的时间还要长。所以让我们来剖析一下我们如何能够重新掌控你的自我怀疑。首先，真正深入到你的消极想法和消极自我信念的背后，问问自己：你实际上在害怕什么？
What are your doubts supposedly warning you of? what are they protecting you from? What is this fear trying to tell you? Like we said before, you know, self-doubt is a form of self-protection. It's saying, you know, failure in this circumstance is scary. Judgment is scary. And we don't want to be exposed to that, so let's play it safe. And what I want you to do is almost like a pro-con analysis of what it would mean to
你的怀疑到底在警告你什么？它们在保护你免受什么伤害？这种恐惧试图告诉你什么？就像我们之前说的，你知道，自我怀疑是一种自我保护的形式。它在说，你知道，在这种情况下失败是可怕的。评判是可怕的。我们不想暴露在那种环境中，所以让我们采取安全策略。而我想让你做的是，做一个利弊分析，看看这意味着什么：
listen to those self-doubts and live with the fear or to live in spying. of it. Let me give you an example. Say you are thinking of moving it to a new city, but you've been going back and forth on it for the last six months. You're doubting yourself, you know, can I do this alone? Am I the kind of person who does these things? Will I have to return in six months and admit that I failed, that I couldn't find a job, that I couldn't adapt, that I couldn't make new friends? What are people going to think of me? Some days you think you can do it and other days you don't think you can. You experience that really awful drop in self-confidence. And so you hold off making the decision. But you feel like you're doing something because you're constantly analyzing and trying to
听从那些自我怀疑，带着恐惧生活，或者在其中挣扎。让我给你举个例子。假设你正考虑搬到一个新的城市，但在过去的六个月里你一直在犹豫不决。你在怀疑自己，你知道，我能一个人完成吗？我是那种会做这种事的人吗？我六个月后不得不回去承认我失败了，我找不到工作，我无法适应，我无法结交新朋友吗？别人会怎么看我？有时你觉得自己能做到，有时又觉得不能。你经历了那次自信心的惨烈暴跌。因此你搁置了这个决定。但你觉得自己好像在做些什么，因为你一直在分析并试图：
essentially determine, do I believe in myself enough to do this? What you might actually be afraid of, what might be fueling this self-doubt is actually more complex. You're not just scared of failing, but you are scared of what others think. You're scared of proving to yourself that you're not capable. You're scared of loneliness. You're scared of your ability to tolerate change and uncertainty. But what is the worst thing that uncertainty or loneliness or change or transition can really do to you? Truly, you'll feel uncomfortable, yes, but you also won't grow. It might be hard. It will take courage, but in a year's time, you'll look back and think, I'm so glad that I did this now. And those memories are going to last for a long time. When you actually go behind your self-doubt, behind why you
从根本上确定：我是否有足够的信念来做到这一点？你真正害怕的、可能在助长这种自我怀疑的东西其实更为复杂。你不仅害怕失败，还害怕别人的看法。你害怕向自己证明你没有能力。你害怕孤独。你害怕自己忍受变化和不确定性的能力。但是，不确定性、孤独、变化或过渡真正能对你做出的最坏的事情是什么？说实话，你会感到不舒服，是的，但你也不会成长。这可能会很困难。这需要勇气，但在一年后，你回过头来看会想，我真高兴我当时这么做了。而这些记忆将持续很长时间。当你真正深入你的自我怀疑背后，深入到你：
question your ability to do something, and you look at what fears are holding up that belief, you realize that what your self-doubt is trying to protect you from is not as scary as what it is protecting you from not doing, if that makes sense. The same goes for things at work or at uni, professionally in your career. What are you actually afraid of? What are your self-doubts trying to protect you from by not going for that promotion, by not applying for that job, by not, you know, starting your own business or creating something new or putting yourself out there. Is it embarrassment? Is it being seen and perceived by others? Is it failure? Is it proving to yourself what you always thought that you don't deserve it anyways? Again, firstly, those fears are probably 99% of the time
质疑自己做某事能力的原因，并审视支撑这种信念的恐惧时，你会意识到，你的自我怀疑试图保护你免受的东西，并不像它保护你免于去做的那些事那样可怕，如果这说得通的话。工作或大学里、职业生涯中的事情也是如此。你究竟在害怕什么？通过不去争取那个晋升、不去申请那份工作、不去（你知道的）自己创业或创造新事物或表现自己，你的自我怀疑试图保护你免受什么伤害？是尴尬吗？是被人看到和感知吗？是失败吗？是向自己证明你一直以来的想法——反正你都不配得到它吗？再说一次，首先，这些恐惧在99%的情况下：
not going to happen. You're not going to embarrass yourself. You're not going to be perceived by others in a negative way that it's going to harm you. But if they do, is it worse than never trying at all? Is the fear of the possibility of something bad happening worth the opportunity of something really good happening? That can be hard to put into practice, by the way. I absolutely understand. But one of the ways that I do it is by personifying my self-doubt and speaking directly
是不会发生的。你不会让自己出丑。你不会以一种会伤害你的负面方式被他人感知。但即使它们发生了，难道比从未尝试过更糟糕吗？坏事发生的可能性带来的恐惧，值得我们去争取一件真正美好的事情的机会吗？顺便说一句，这很难付诸实践。我完全理解。但我做到这一点的方法之一，就是将我的自我怀疑人格化，并直接与它对话：
to it with compassion and gratitude. I know this sounds really silly, but just try it. say to yourself doubt, like, hey, I really appreciate you looking out for me. That is so nice of you. Thank you so much for anticipating those things. I really appreciate all the extra work that you're doing. But I've got it from here. I'm going to do it anyways.
带着同情和感恩。我知道这听起来很傻，但试一试吧。对你的自我怀疑说，嘿，我真的很感激你照顾我。你太好了。非常感谢你预料到这些事情。我真的很感激你所做的所有额外工作。但从这里开始我来接管。无论如何我都会去做。
And we can revisit later on. We'll circle back. The thing to remember is that you are your self-doubts. You own them. They come from you. And so you can say no to them as well. You can say, yeah, no, I actually don't believe that. Sorry.
我们以后可以再讨论。我们会回过头来的。要记住的一点是，你就是你的自我怀疑。它们属于你。它们来自你。所以你也可以对它们说不。你可以说，不，不，我其实不相信那个。抱歉。
Actually, no, like, that's probably not going. to happen. So thank you for that thought. You're wrong, moving on. The other thing that really helps me with this and helps me put things into perspective is to remind myself that other people, people that I admire, pretty much have the same internal self-scepticism and doubts as me. It's very easy to compare ourselves to the people around us, these incredibly successful people, and kind of believe that the only reason they have what we dream of is because they were always confident in their ability to do so, or that everything has worked out for them, that they have none of these self-doubts when actually so many of the greats, so many of the people we really
事实上，不，那可能不会发生。所以谢谢你提出这个想法。你错了，继续前进。真正对我有帮助、能帮我看清局势的另一件事是提醒自己，其他人——我钦佩的人——基本上也和我有着同样的内心自我怀疑和犹豫。把我们自己周围的人、这些极其成功的人进行比较是非常容易的，并且会下意识地认为他们拥有我们梦寐以求的东西的唯一原因，是因为他们对自己的能力总是充满自信，或者一切对他们来说都很顺利，他们没有这些自我怀疑，而实际上许多伟大的人、许多我们真正：
admire have had setbacks. They have had crippling doubts that they have had to overcome to be who they are now. The person I always think of when it comes to this is Simone Biles. the Olympics are coming up. She's a great example. She's the most decorated gymnast, one of the most accomplished Olympians in history. And a few years back, she gave this interview saying that there had been so many times when she didn't think that she was good enough, when she was so hypercritical of her performance that, in her words, she couldn't remember a day where she didn't cry. We each come to our dreams and our desires and our plans with doubts. even those who you would never believe would falter or for one second think that they weren't great
钦佩的人都经历过挫折。他们经历过让人瘫痪的怀疑，必须克服这些怀疑才能成为今天的自己。每当想到这一点，我脑海中浮现的人总是西蒙娜·拜尔斯。奥运会就要到了。她是一个很好的例子。她是获得奖牌最多的体操运动员，也是历史上成就最高的奥运选手之一。几年前，她接受了一次采访，说曾有无数次她觉得自己不够好，她对自己的表现吹毛求疵，用她的话说，她记不起有哪一天她没有哭过。我们每个人带着怀疑面对我们的梦想、渴望和计划。甚至那些你绝不会相信会动摇、哪怕一秒钟觉得自己不够伟大的人：
because they are the best. Imposter syndrome still strikes them down. It's like the natural equalizer. And when you realize that even these incredible athletes, incredible people have these feelings, you also begin to realize that maybe the only difference between them and maybe the people who aren't on that podium, maybe us, is that they didn't let that fear at the root of their self-doubt overwhelm them. Here is the other reason why I think having these kinds of realistic idols and seeing these examples and hearing them speak about it is so helpful for soothing our self-doubts. It really helps us ask the question, you know, why not me? Why can't I have that? Why can't I be her? Why can't I dream big or take the chances that they have? Because we have the same self-doubts.
因为他们是最好的。冒名顶替综合症仍然会击垮他们。这就像是一种自然的平衡器。当你意识到甚至这些不可思议的运动员、不可思议的人也有这些感受时，你也开始意识到，也许他们和那些没有站在领奖台上的人（也许是我们）之间唯一的真正区别在于，他们没有让植根于自我怀疑底层的恐惧压倒他们。这就是为什么我认为拥有这种现实的偶像、看到这些例子并听他们谈论对缓解我们的自我怀疑如此有帮助的另一个原因。它真正帮助我们问出这个问题，你知道，为什么不是我？为什么我不能拥有那个？为什么我不能成为她？为什么我不能胸怀大志或抓住他们所拥有的机会？因为我们有着同样的自我怀疑。
They've just found a place for them. They've set the example. They have proven that it's possible. it's kind of your turn. Maybe you don't want to be an Olympic gymnast, but, you know, whatever it is that you are striving towards, there is an example of somebody in that professional in your career who has experienced the most crippling form of self-doubt and pushed beyond it. And I want us to just sit for a second and really ponder that question. Whatever it is that your self-doubt is keeping you back from, why not you? And I want you to give me at least three reasons. chances are you can't because your fear and your self-doubt is not actually rational. It's just kind of betting on you listening to it blindly and obeying what it's telling you to do,
他们只是为它们找到了一个位置。他们树立了榜样。他们证明了这是可能的。现在轮到你了。也许你不想成为一名奥运体操运动员，但是，无论你正在为什么而奋斗，在你的职业生涯中总会有这样一个例子：某个人经历了最令人麻痹的自我怀疑，并超越了它。我想让我们坐下来一会儿，真正思考这个问题。无论是什么在阻碍你的自我怀疑，为什么不是你？我希望你能给我至少三个理由。很有可能你给不出来，因为你的恐惧和自我怀疑实际上并不理性。它只是在押注你会盲目地听从它，服从它告诉你要做的事：
being indecisive, it's betting on you not taking risks, it's betting on you playing it safe. When actually, when you really drill down into it, the reasons to not do something are often a lot less persuasive than the reasons to do something. Here's how we counteract that. Make a persona for yourself, create a version of you, visualize a character that would do all the things that you believe that you can't. Base that persona off of the people you admire who did what you dream to do, even if they're fictional. Base that persona off of your ideal vision of your future self or your idols or your wildest dreams and give them a name. And then the question is between downing yourself and doing the thing, whatever it is, ask yourself, okay, what would my persona do?
优柔寡断，它在押注你不会冒险，押注你选择稳妥。而实际上，当你真正深入钻研时，不做某事的理由通常远没有去做的理由那么有说服力。以下是我们如何进行反击的方法。为自己塑造一个角色，创造一个版本的你，想象一个会去做所有你认为自己做不到的事情的角色。将这个角色建立在你钦佩的人的基础之上——那些做了你梦想做的事的人，即使他们是虚构的。以你对未来自己的理想愿景、你的偶像或你最大胆的梦想为基础，给他们起个名字。然后，在怀疑自己和做这件事（无论是什么）之间的问题是，问问自己，好吧，我的角色会怎么做？
What would this version of me who is everything I want to be, who is all the great parts of everybody else that I love and I admire? Would they take the risk? You know, they wouldn't think twice. Would they put themselves out there? Of course they would. Would they wear this weird outfit? Of course they would.
这个版本的我会怎么做？她是我想要成为的一切，拥有我爱和钦佩的每个人的所有美好部分？她会冒险吗？你知道，她不会犹豫。她会展现自己吗？她当然会。她会穿这件奇怪的衣服吗？她当然会。
And there you go. They are the justification for doing all the things that you maybe wouldn't do otherwise. be like, you know, well, I wasn't going to take that solo trip, but Patricia, my alter ego made me. She wanted me to go, so I guess I have to go. I wasn't going to apply for that promotion or ask that person out, but, you know, Ronaldo would do it. And I've got to, you know, do it for Ronaldo. I've got to do it for this alter ego. I've got to be this version and vision of me that I believe in and that is possible. Become that persona, become this alter ego. You know, make them responsible for the, for the things that you are scared to do.
就这样。他们就是去做你平时可能不会做的一切事情的正当理由。你会说，你知道，我本来不打算进行那次单人旅行，但帕特里夏，我的另一个我（分身）逼我去的。她想让我去，所以我想我只能去。我本来不打算申请那个晋升或者约那个人出去，但是，你知道的，罗纳尔多会这么做的。我得为罗纳尔多这么做。我得为这个另一个我这么做。我得成为我相信的、也是可能的这个版本的自己和愿景。成为那个角色，成为这个另一个我。你知道，让他们为你害怕去做的事情承担责任。
The benefits of this are amazing, greater performance, greater confidence, more willpower, quicker decision making. In psychology, it's called the Batman effect. And the reason it works is because it allows us to separate ourselves from all the negative beliefs, our past, our memories, whatever is holding us back. And it projects only the best parts of ourselves onto this, you know, I don't want to say false, this fantasy version of us. it kind of reigns in the undesirable feelings that are holding us back through this very effective
这样做的好处是惊人的：更好的表现、更大的自信、更强的意志力、更快的决策能力。在心理学中，这被称为“蝙蝠侠效应”。它之所以起作用，是因为它允许我们将自己与所有消极的信念、我们的过去、我们的记忆以及任何阻碍我们的东西剥离开来。它只把我们最好的一部分投射到这个（我不想说虚假的）幻想版本的我们身上。它通过这种非常有效的自我疏离形式，驾驭并控制了阻碍我们的不良情绪。
form of self-distancing. When I want to stop getting in my own way, I think about what Gemma with G would do. She wouldn't think about other's opinions before her own. Gemma with the G is totally confident, totally self-aware. She wouldn't doubt herself before she expressed what she was feeling. She wouldn't stop herself saying yes to cool things or going places where she knew no one. That's what Gemma with a G would do. And I want to do right by her. So try this persona alter ego tip for just a week. Apply it where necessary and see if it changes anything.
当我想停止阻碍自己时，我会想带G的杰玛会怎么做。她不会在自己的意见之前先考虑别人的意见。带G的杰玛完全自信，完全有自我意识。她在表达自己的感受之前不会怀疑自己。她不会阻止自己对酷炫的事情说“不”，或者去她不认识任何人的地方。带G的杰玛就会这么做。我想为她做好榜样。所以，请尝试这个角色/分身小贴士，只需一周时间。在必要的地方应用它，看看它是否能改变任何事情。
It's almost like thinking from a place of your ideal self rather than your scared self, rather than your doubting self. If your self-doubt is especially linked to procrastination and indecisiveness, I would also say train yourself to not do things perfectly every time. Treat failure like an assignment almost and just do go to the gym even if you don't end up working out right? You still went, you still made a decision to go. Wear an outfit even if you know it doesn't look great just for like a couple of hours. Put your hand up to host that event or to go to that run club or anything that means you will show up even if you don't show up perfectly because what matters most is just being decisive and doing.
这几乎就像是从你的理想自我而不是恐惧自我、怀疑自我的角度思考。如果你的自我怀疑特别与拖延和优柔寡断有关，我也会说，训练自己不要每次都把事情做到完美。几乎把失败当作一项作业，只管去做——即使你最后没有去锻炼，也要去健身房，对吧？你还是去了，你还是做出了去的决定。穿一件衣服，即使你知道它看起来不是很好，哪怕只穿几个小时。举手主持那个活动，或者去那个跑步俱乐部的活动，或者做任何意味着你会出现的事情，即使你表现得不够完美，因为最重要的是果断行动。
That is what we are trying to train ourselves into. You are allowed to make mistakes. You don't have to do it perfectly. That's okay. And you build up this tolerance for failure. And failure is often the thing that our self-doubt is most scared of. It's like when you do cold water plunges, right? It feels so terrible at the beginning.
这就是我们试图训练自己去做的。你被允许犯错。你不需要做到完美。这没关系。你建立对失败的忍耐力。而失败往往是我们的自我怀疑最害怕的事情。就像你进行冷水浴一样，对吧？一开始感觉太糟糕了。
But soon you begin to relax into it and realize that this actually isn't that scary. This actually isn't dangerous. My brain is just trying to convince me that it is to protect me. This also doesn't give us time to get stuck in the analysis loop of do I do it, do I not, am I deserving, am I not? Because our assignment is to disregard those things and just do. It's that simple. Make it that simple.
但很快你就会开始放松下来，意识到这其实并没有那么可怕。这其实并不危险。我的大脑只是在试图说服我是为了保护我。这也并没有给我们时间陷入“我该做还是不该做，我配不配”的分析循环中。因为我们的任务是无视这些事情，直接去做。就是这么简单。让它变得如此简单。
Just do it. Oh my God. Hopefully I don't get sued by Nike for using their phrase. That was completely accidental. But again, ask the question, what are you truly afraid of? Get behind those fears. And is there a chance that your doubts are incorrect? That is the final part of this.
只管去做。天哪。希望我使用耐克的口号不会被他们起诉。那完全是偶然的。但再次重申，问问自己：你究竟在害怕什么？深入了解这些恐惧。你的怀疑有没有可能是错误的？这是这部分的最后一部分。
My final tip for this episode, question what your brain is trying to convince you is fact. And remember that if your doubts came from you, there is a possibility that they might be biased or maybe wrong. A lot of the time they are based on this incorrect or faulty evidence. You know, this faulty evidence from our past experiences that incorrectly made us assume that we weren't worthy, we weren't valuable, we weren't talented. we weren't intelligent. And because those doubts are actually originating from inside of you, they have an internal origin. Once again, you can choose to say, yeah, you know, I don't think that's right. I'm just going to choose to not believe this today. I'm going to choose to not believe that I don't deserve this. I'm going to believe that there wasn't a mistake, that I didn't just
本集的最后一个小贴士：质疑你的大脑试图让你相信是事实的东西。请记住，如果你的怀疑来自于你，它们就有可能是带有偏见的，或者是错误的。很多时候，它们是基于这些不正确或有缺陷的证据。你知道，这些来自我们过去的错误证据错误地让我们假设我们不值得，我们没有价值，我们没有天赋，我们不聪明。而且因为这些怀疑实际上起源于你的内部，它们有一个内部的起源。再次，你可以选择说，是的，你知道，我认为那是不对的。我今天只想选择不相信这个。我选择不相信我不配得到这个。我相信没有犯错，我不是刚刚好运，我来这里是有原因的，因为这种信念和我的自我怀疑都来自我，它们都有可能是真的。所以我无论如何都要去做。无论如何我都要做我自己。无论如何我都会出席。一些最后的提醒，因为你知道我喜欢用一点鼓励的话来结束我的节目，为你打气，让你去应用我希望你学到的东西。请记住，我们大多数人并不是一出场就一飞冲天的。
get lucky, that I'm here for a reason because that belief and my self-doubt are both coming from me and they both have the capacity to be true. So I'm going to do it anyways. I'm going to be myself anyways. I'm going to show up anyways. Some final reminders, because you know I love to close my episodes out with a little pep talk to hype you guys up to get you to apply what I'm hoping you've learned. Please remember that most of us don't just explode right out the gate.
我们大多数人都花了一些时间在某种程度上怀疑自己的能力。区别在于你是让这定义了你的现实，还是只让它成为一个想法。当你的内心批评声很大时，这可能很困难，但再次强调，你的内心批评者就是你自己的声音。你和你的内心批评者是同一个人。所以你实际上能够用更好、更真实的对你是谁的理解来取代那些信念，即你是一个有能力、自信、敢于冒险、愿意押注自己的人，是一个从挫折中学习的人，如果你已经看到了这里，显然你非常致力于成为最好的自己。所以不要让自己成为阻碍你前进的罪魁祸首。不要，你知道的，到了生命的尽头才意识到，从来没有人真正对你说过不，或者把你拒之门外。你在他们有机会之前就自己拒绝了。所以你从来没有真正，你知道的，让自己参与竞争。我不希望那是你的现实。所以我通过麦克风给你一个大大的拥抱，还有一个大大的“你他妈的可以做到”，因为你能。你绝对可以。你的自我怀疑不能控制你。像往常一样，我真的希望你喜欢这一集。至少，我希望你学到了关于你自己、关于你的生活或关于你的心理学的新东西。
Most of us do spend some time doubting our own abilities in some capacity. the difference is whether you let that define your reality or you let it just be a thought. It can be hard when your inner critic is loud, but once again, your inner critic is your own voice. You and your inner critic are one and the same. So you are actually able to replace those beliefs with a better and more real understanding of who you are, which is someone who is competent, confident, a risk taker willing to bet on themselves, someone who learns from setbacks and who, if you've made it this far, is obviously deeply committed to becoming your best self. So don't let yourself be to blame for, I guess,
我们大多数人在某种程度上都会花时间怀疑自己的能力。区别在于你是让这种怀疑定义了你的现实，还是仅仅让它成为一个想法。当你的内心批评者声音很大时，这可能会很难，但再说一次，你的内心批评者就是你自己的声音。你和你的内心批评者是同一个人。所以你其实有能力用更好、更真实的自我认知来取代那些信念，即你是一个有能力、自信、敢于冒险、愿意押注自己的人，是一个从挫折中吸取教训的人，而且如果你能坚持到这里，显然你深深致力于成为最好的自己。所以不要让自己成为阻碍，我猜，
holding you back. Don't, you know, get to the end of your life and realize that nobody ever actually said no or turned you away or turned you down. You did it before they even had the chance. So you never really, you know, put yourself in the running. I don't want that to be your reality. So I'm giving you a big hug through the microphone and a big you can fucking do it because you can. You absolutely can. Your self-doubts do not control you. And as always, I just really hope that you enjoyed this episode. At the least, I hope that you learned something new about yourself, about your life or about your psychology.
拖了后腿。你知道，不要等到生命的尽头才发现，其实从来没有人说过不，也没有人把你推开或拒绝你。你甚至在他们有机会之前就自己否定了自己。所以你从来没有真正参与竞争。我不希望那是你的现实。所以我通过麦克风给你一个大大的拥抱，以及一句强有力的“你他妈一定能做到”，因为你真的可以。你绝对可以。你的自我怀疑并不能控制你。和往常一样，我真的希望你喜欢这一集。至少，我希望你关于自己、生活或心理学学到了一些新的东西。
As always, if you feel like there is somebody in your life who could benefit from this, please feel free to share it with them. make sure that you are following along for new episodes. I just got to say we've got some amazing ones coming out soon. I am so excited for next week's episode in particular. Maybe it's already out by the time you're listening to this, but listen to that one next, if that is the case. And if you could give us a five-star review on Apple Podcasts or Spotify,
像往常一样，如果你觉得你生活中有谁可以从中受益，请随时与他们分享。确保你关注了新节目。我不得不说，我们很快就会推出一些精彩的内容。我特别为下周的节目感到兴奋。也许当你听到这个节目的时候它已经上线了，但如果是这样的话，接下来听那一集吧。如果你能在 Apple Podcasts 或 Spotify 上给我们一个五星好评，
that also really helps the show to grow and reach a new audience. If you enjoyed this episode, if you have feedback, and more importantly, if you have a topic suggestion, something about the psychology of your 20s that we have not yet covered. I would love to hear from you. Make sure that you are following along at that psychology podcast. Or you can follow me at Gemma Spake. And until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself,
那也将对节目的成长和接触新的听众非常有帮助。如果你喜欢这一集，如果你有反馈，更重要的是，如果你有话题建议——关于20多岁心理学中我们尚未涵盖的内容——我很乐意听到你的声音。确保在“that psychology podcast”上关注我们。或者你可以在“Gemma Spake”关注我。直到下一次，注意安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点，
and we will talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
我们很快再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身和建立韧性的科学：
in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover
在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中。经历一些苦难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即数字 2 和百分号，在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现：
they've all dated the same prolific con artist, They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
在 iHeart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说更重要了。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed Human.
你正在收听的是由你最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，在其他任何地方进行这些对话真的都不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证是人类制作。
Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。